all right so um what have we seen today
so we saw a lot of uh
uh
recent progress on the front of uh on
the optimization fronts and the learning
front uh around min max optimization
we saw an application of wind max in
reinforcement learning
and for our last talk uh today
it's a pleasure to introduce nathan
kalos from uh cornell who's going to
talk about uh
a whole different application of minmax
optimization now in the context of
causal inference so nathan take it away
thanks costas and thanks so much for
having me
i'm sorry i can't be there in person i
have some child care responsibilities
here at home but i'm hoping to
be there later this semester
so
i thought i would tell you about work
that's drawing with my student andrew on
the variation method of moments which is
essentially going to be about applying
mini max optimization to solving
conditional moment problems
so for motivation let me start with the
iv problem
so here what i did is i took this orange
curve
and i generated data from it by picking
some
points x
and then generating uh
an observation by looking at the orange
point with some noise
uh in particular you can think about
this maybe as
you know some
dosage of sulfonylurea which is
something that's supposed to increase
the secretion of insulin in the blood
and then the insulin level so we expect
a positive relationship
but the way i generate this data
actually is trying to kind of
simulate something that might occur in
reality where maybe patients with the
more severe disease are given higher
doses
right so really we're trying to capture
a sort of
constant incident level there's an
insulin target that we're trying to get
at and indeed if we look at the
correlations between safaria dosage and
insulin levels it looks roughly flat if
we just estimate that conditional
expectation but that doesn't reflect the
actual causal effect which is here in
orange
and that's because what i did was i
exactly
planted endogenous in this problem so
that individuals with warsaw disease
were also given higher doses
so this is a problem
called endogenating and one way to solve
it is what's known as an iv is to look
for some source of randomization here's
z which is only influencing the outcome
y here the incident level via its effect
on x the action or other endogenous
variables here levels of sulfonylurea
so the iv model looks something like
this we have some sort of structural
generative causal model that is saying
this is how x actually gives us y
there's some function theta naught that
takes x and gives us y plus some noise
but because of endogeneity
actually the expectation of the noise
given the variables is not equal to zero
this is
like what this is the
math of what the words endogenicity mean
and therefore if we look at the
predictive model of actually looking at
the regression of y given x
that predictive model is going to be
distinct from this structural generative
causal model that we want so we don't
just want to do regression
right so iv is this tool that is very
common in applications like econo
econometrics
that has
some
special properties uh that's essentially
capturing the fact that it's giving us
some sort of natural randomization in
order to capture some sort of quasi
experiment that's hidden in the data so
one of the conditions has to satisfy is
exclusion
so in some sense it should only affect y
via x which we write by saying that it
should be in some sense uncorrelated
with the noise epsilon so its only
effect is via x okay so we say
expectation epsilon of z equals zero and
it should also affect x in some
sufficient manner so that it captures
all the variations in x at least in as
much as they matter for the functions
that we're trying to fit okay and if we
have these conditions then we have that
theta naught this data not the one that
we really want actually uniquely solve
this moment equation over all
thetas in our class of thetas right and
this class of theta was had to match the
one for the relevance
in particular
it should be the case that if we look at
the residuals
once we subtract from y our
causal prediction of it theta x
those which israel's residuals should be
mean independent of z so the means of
the residuals given z should be equal to
zero this is coming directly from the
exclusion and the uniqueness is coming
from the relevance so this very general
type of model is sort of a workhorse of
empirical research in econ there's so
many examples of different cases of
trying to understand for example
how veteran status affects earning
by trying to understand uh the draft
lottery number as a natural experiment
or another famous one that recently won
a nobel prize for david card is
understanding uh the effect of years of
schooling on earnings but of course
those things are endogenous uh via some
sort of underlying
skill or you know parentage
so using proximity to college as an
instrument
and going beyond iv essentially what
we're dealing with here is a conditional
moment problem that
is something that shows up in a lot of
settings beyond just ib regression so
the conditional moment problem is the
following problem so in iv we had
theta naught solves this moment
conditional moment it's a conditional
moment because there's a conditioning on
z here now we're going to say more
generally we're going to observe some
observations o this is our random
variable
and we're going to have some function
that's known to us rho that takes o and
theta and we're going to say theta
naught is the one that uniquely solves
this moment equation which is now in m
dimensions so before we had just one
dimension but generally would have m
moment conditions okay and what we
observe
is these observations o
and z is just some aspect of o it's some
o measurable uh variable and we want to
learn estimate make inferences on state
or not all right so what are some
examples of this we only talked about
one example and that's instrumental
variables in this case
the observations consisted of
the instrument right it's the natural
source of randomness that affects x
and then only affects y v x and that was
our observations right and here z is all
measurable because it's just that first
element of o
and we only had one moment because we're
looking at a univariate outcome there's
a lot of other examples not just iv
for example there's the blp model an
industrial organization uh it's
essentially a just more complicated id
model with some discrete choice built in
that helps us understand market shares
but beyond econometrics this model is
actually
used to model q functions and marginal
density ratios in offline rl so this is
exactly those primal dual mini max
algorithms that jason was mentioning
we can also tell us some stuff about
actually doing offline policy learning
when we have circuit losses i may get
the time to talk about that as well
it shows up when we talk about proximal
causal inference within causal influence
under uh when we have unmeasured
confounders but instead we can use
negative controls to control for the
confounders it also shows up in panel
data with confounders
and this paper is actually interesting
in this paper what we
had to deal with is actually this is an
example
where theta naught might not actually be
unique so for the rest of this talk i'm
just going to focus on you know let's
just assume it's unique and deal with
that but sometimes it's not and you have
to think about how to target some sort
of minimal such function and the
examples are endless
now the question is how do you actually
solve this problem right so you have you
want to find the theta naught such that
when you project rho o theta on z that
way in a variable is a zero random
variable how do we do that
so the first thing we might try is to
reduce this to an easier problem the
marginal moment problem so here what
we're going to do is we're going to fix
some test functions f j which map z to
rm
okay then we can stack them all together
so we're going to take k of these stack
them all together into a vector value
sorry matrix valued function okay it's
going to be k by m
and then we're going to form the
k moments that we get when we multiply
rho by f
because the conditional expectation was
zero so should the correlation of rho
with any function of z be zero right so
we can test this with these k different
functions
right there's a missing transpose right
here so that is essentially just the
vector of length k where in the jth
entry we have f j of z transpose rho
okay so those k marginal moments should
be equal to zero and that is one way to
try and find theta naught because we
know that or not at least satisfies
these things
okay so we reduced it to the marginal
moment problem but how do we solve the
marginal moment problem
well there's some very famous work about
this
known as the generalized method of
moments so this is by hanson
it's essentially
one of the big reasons he won the nobel
prize
and the approach goes like this
we're going to take these k moments
right we have these k marginal moments
so we want to set all of them to zero we
want to find the theta naught that sets
all of them to zero
we can't compute the moments exactly
instead we're going to compute the
empirical version of the moments right
so it's replacing expectations with
empirical expectations whenever i write
e sub n i'm talking about this empirical
average over the data
so now we have k empirical modes we want
to minimize all of them we want to make
all of them zero okay but we can't
control all of them at the same time so
we're going to minimize some two norm of
them
but the two norm is going to be weighted
by some special weighting matrix
which is uh given by this formula here
okay so we're going to essentially try
and control the two norm of this
empirical moments
vector
and the two norm is going to be
controlled by this matrix which is given
by some initial estimate of theta tilde
which is essentially trying to just give
us an understanding of the covariance of
these moment conditions
and why is
the optimally weighted gmm as i'm going
to call it so good well
one benefit is that it's consistent and
it's asymptotically normal if theta
naught is indeed the one that uniquely
solves this right these k moments
marginal ones so if it's really you have
a marginal moment problem then that's
great this is what you should do it's
consistent asymptotic normal means we
could do inference it's even going to be
semi-parametrically efficient in the
model given by all distributions that
satisfy these moment conditions okay as
long as our initial estimate is
consistent which we can always do by
just running gmm plugging gmm into
optimum weighted gmm and uh be able to
ensure this so that's great it gives us
everything we want consistency ups and
top normality and efficiency but it has
a lot of limitations one is
this assumption that theta not uniquely
solves this is pretty big we were
already not sure if it solves the you
know really solves the conditional
moment problem uniquely
and in other words it might not identify
theta naught it's not unique right and
that pretty much shows up in anything
that isn't linearizing so if you have
linear iv right so you have
instrumental variable regression where
that theta naught is a linear function
then you know how to identify it
but anything else pretty much is is not
going to work it's not enough to solve
the conditional moment problem in
addition even if you're in that
identifying case like linear iv it's not
going to be efficient in the full
conditional model it's only efficient in
this sub model
right
so that's actually almost anything that
isn't both linear v with a linear
first stage regression so pretty much
anything
okay so what should we do
we should try and tackle more than just
a few functions
and so that brings rise to some uh
approaches that have been suggested
called sieve approaches to this so we
can take optimally weighted gmm and
combine it with some sort of c like a
growing set of test functions so this
was uh
back in the 87 done by chamberlain and
more recently refined quite a lot and
extended to other settings by
iron chen
so here we're just going to let the test
functions
form the first kn elements of some bases
for l2 and let k go to infinity permit
polynomials fourier bases b splines etc
so that's one thing we could do we could
also directly estimate the efficient
instrument there is actually a set of m
uh test functions that are sufficient
they give us efficiency they're just
unknown they involve some complicated
conditional expectation so knew we said
we know what these are in theory let's
try and form them and then we're going
to estimate you know this regression
function
matrix value the regression function
using non-parametric uh regression using
sieves same thing with this vector value
regression and actually plug in f star
into optimally weighted gmat
so the good thing is that these are
efficient under appropriate conditions
the bad thing is that these are
kind of unusable in practice
when theta and z are just moderately
dimensional
right we look at this regression if we
have theta being moderately dimensional
the
size of this vector could be big
uh if
z is high dimensional or just moderate
dimensional this non-parametric
regression is going to be really really
hard to do right what we want to do is
not use all this classical nonparametric
statistics
that's not so useful in modern
dimensions we want to use something more
machine learning work
so that has recently given rise to these
minimax approaches for this problem so
the minimax approach would take some to
go something like this instead of just
fixing k test functions we're going to
look at a rich class of test functions
right a big class of functions from
input space z to r to the n remember m
is the number of moments that we're
trying to set to zero
right it's a number of conditional
moments
for example this set could be neural
nets with m outputs product of
is etcetera etcetera and then what we're
going to do is we're going to look for
theta
that would minimize
all of these moments for all of these
f's in this class of functions right so
we're trying to find theta that would
make many many many many moments equal
to zero in a big rich class of functions
so we can not just use k moments just k
test functions we can use a whole rkhs a
whole neural net and that's something
that's been proposed in a variety of
recent work and actually shown to to
work quite well in a lot of those
applications like offline or rail iv
regression et cetera
but there are limitations to this as
well
so first on the positives the benefits
are that identification is now much more
plausible as long as f is sort of going
to be dense in l2
we're done this is exactly the same
thing as the conditional moment problem
right we haven't made any sort of
assumption that we found case efficient
things to identify
there's no longer crazy sieves no omit
polynomials and unwieldy stuff like that
no splines it's much more ml like right
put a neural net in it maybe you grow
the neuromas put an rkhs in it stuff
like that
and this
uh in particular
this paper that i want to point out in
particular gives us rates for how fast
we learn theta not when we think about
non-parametric classes for theta and for
f and i believe the c list will tell us
about this later this week
there's also some limitations here
first of all efficiency
right so you can get consistency you can
get rates
but
even if you get scored n rates what's
the constant in front right are we doing
this efficiently even when we talked
about
that classic marginal moment problem
you can easily get
skirt and consistency without doing any
special weighting but the efficiency
that noble uh
nobel prize winning efficiency came from
optimal waiting and the problem here is
there's a lot of moments right there's
infinitely many moments we don't know
which moment should wait more or less
there's going to be a lot of difficult
moments that kind of are correlated we
really have to worry about
to control the right moments that matter
and not control the nouns that don't
matter don't
waste your time trying to
make theta control the moments that
actually don't matter so much
right and that's going to matter a lot
in practice uh and actually will be
important for actually getting
semi-parametric efficiency in addition
while we're able to get these rates for
non-america's theta
the question is but what about infants
we want something like asymptotic
normality so we can do plus minus two
standard errors
because maybe what we're trying to do
here is we're trying to do you know
economics we're trying to do social
science we want to make claims about
things that are out there in the real
world we want to put confidence
intervals on things and make claims that
are true we want to do inference right
so that's kind of a big deal so what i'm
going to try and do in today's talk is
try to tackle how do we get these two
efficiency and inference within the
context of minimax approaches to the
conditional moment problem
so that's going to be
what i'm going to set out to do
and that's going to lead me exactly
directly to the method the
variational method of moments that i'm
going to propose which is going to
try and tackle those things so my plan
is going to be present this methodology
then show you the guarantees for this
methodology we're going to go through
consistency asymptotic normality and
semiparametric efficiency so all the
things that we want
and then we're also going to talk about
how to actually do inference with this
so it's going to be asymptotically
normal but we also have to estimate the
asymptotic variance so that we know how
to do plus minus two standards like what
are those standard errors so we'll talk
about again a mini max on top of minimax
algorithm that's going to give us the
inference
i'll talk a little bit about experiments
and if there's time we'll see where we
get i literally just put these slides
together so i just put extra stuff there
in case uh there's lots of time but it's
not about what you cover it's about what
you uncover so we'll see what we get if
there's time i'll talk about applying
this vmm methodology for policy learning
and applying this vm methodology for off
policy evaluation when you see
confounded observate observations from a
palmdp so a sort of confounded version
of offline reinforcement learning but
for now let's just talk about the
variational method of moments
so
before going to the variational method
of moments let's talk go back and talk
about optimally weighted gmm what i'm
going to try and do is i'm going to
start with optimally weighted gmm and
from there
go to a mini-map formulation of it
so that that we can then generalize for
uh rich function classes right we want
to inherit this efficient optimal
weighting that hanson gave us
okay so toward that end let's recall
what optimally weighted gmm was it said
let's take k test functions and we're
going to pick theta hat n
to minimize the vector norm of these
k moments
right empirical moments weighted by some
appropriate
matrix it's going to give us the right
euclidean norm to minimize right it's
going to weight the moments in the
appropriate way so that we get
efficiency
so
you can actually just
rewrite this
euclidean norm
using duality as a soup so it goes
something like this
if we fix f to be the linear space of
functions right so linear space of
functions from z to r to the m
which is given by the span of these kf's
right literally for any combination any
betas we're gonna
there should be no transpose beta here
that's a typo we're going to look at
mapping z to some linear combinations of
f j
then we can show that this optimally
weighted gmm is equivalent to the
following we're going to minimize over
theta the supremum over all functions f
in the span okay so now this is calling
to mind the minimax approaches from
before but this is not any different
from optimally weighted gmm this is
optimally weighted gmm so we're looking
at the supremum over all test functions
f in the span
of the empirical moment that this test
function gives us
minus some regularization
that accounts for the
variance of this okay and this will
actually be one to one equal to the
above just by equilibrium normal duality
but now this is very very suggestive
now that we have a soup f over f we can
say
let's just switch out f by other
function classes and just hope
that we've inherited the nice properties
of optimally weighted gmm okay that's
going to be the plan of attack
so just let's define dmm here first
specifically so vmm is going to be given
by
a choice of function class fn
a choice of some initial guess for theta
not theta tilde n usually we're just
going to be using the previous iterate
so we're going to try first get an
estimate plugging in get a new estimate
two rounds will be enough but we can
proceed more rounds if we want to
and some regularize it regularizer fast
okay so let's work through these terms
what is going on here what are we trying
to do
this purple term
over here is trying to make all the
moments zero this was the same
motivation as in the minimax approaches
we have a lot of test functions we want
to make sure that the moments with
respect to each test function is made
very very small so that's the first term
but
we need to know what is kind of the
relative importance of different moments
that's the second term it's telling us
you know
make certain moments with certain test
functions less important or more
important
accordingly to their variance
finally
we're going to control the complexity of
our function class by either changing
the set of functions we're looking at
and or
choosing a regularizer there's some sort
of redundancy there but because of the
flexibility this allows us i'm going to
include both
a possibility for choosing growing
function classes and
having some regularizing okay so that's
the vmm
right now i'm saying we're going to
minimize this but we can actually also
permit some approximate optimization we
can have that theta n is only
approximately optimizing the supremum
which will be useful in practice and is
not going to change any of the results
but to keep things simple and
straightforward we're just going to
stick to exact optimization for now
okay
so as i alluded to
we can also uh right the question is
where did theta tilde come from well it
goes like this you can just
apply vmm on top of emm so you
initialize some guess for the
parameters maybe just all zeros whatever
you want
and then you're just gonna use that
previous iterate as your current guess
theta tilde in order to control
this orange term and then you're going
to find your next guess for theta hat
n
and then you can keep doing this k times
you only really need to do this two
times you can do this multiple times if
you wanted to
okay so this is kind of a generic recipe
let's talk about specific variants of
kmn
of vmm so one variant would be to
instantiate everything with kernels
right so let's say that h is going to be
some reproducing kernel hybrid space or
rkhs so example gaussian kernel products
of m sub level series is whatever we
want we're going to set fn to be this
rkhs and we're
independent of n and we're going to set
the regularizer to be
given by the squared gilbert norm of the
function f okay so that's one variant of
the mmm this is the variant that we're
actually going to focus on in the theory
but another variant we could do is uh
use neural nets to instantialize
everything so we're going to set fn the
class of functions to be a class of
neural networks with some given
architecture
and unknown weights and the architecture
could be growing right so later we're
going to talk about a fully connected
neural net that has growing width and
growing depth
and there's different regularizers we
can choose so one regularizer i'll talk
about is the kernel regularizer so
essentially use the same regularizer as
from the kernel vmm these functions
right these neural nets are not actually
in the arc address so instead you're
going to look at the function that
interpolates the neural nets at every
data point right it's going to exist if
we're going to look at universal arches
like this
and look at its norm right so the norm
of the minimal interpolating
element of the rkhs and use that as a
regularizer
this looks a bit complicated it has some
infinite but it has some closed form
it's some quadratic in the evaluations
of f and zi
uh we could also just regularize the
squares of the values that uh
f takes on zi
and
that's
going to
approximate essentially doing this
kernel regularizer with a gaussian
kernel with very tiny length scale so
this is sort of heuristic practical
version of this uh which is what we're
going to implement in practice in the
experiments but this kernel regularizer
is what we're going to study
okay so before i talk about
guarantees let me talk really quickly
about how we actually compute this
right so vmm here is given by smooth
games i guess that's why i'm here today
telling you about it it's a game between
theta and the test functions f and
optimizing some potential right so how
do we solve it i don't know i guess the
people in the room are way better
equipped to tell me how to do it i'll
tell you how i've done any experiments
you probably know how to do it better
right so for kernel vmm the inner soup
actually has some closed form you can
write as a convex quadratic in the
values that the
moment function row takes right so it's
going to be some conductor gradient in
these and then we're going to optimize
over theta
uh it's going to be in terms of some
of the kernel gram matrix and the value
of the moments at this initial guess
data theta tilde okay and then we can
directly apply usual optimization
algorithms to this because there's no
soup anymore we solved the closed form
for neural nets uh it gets a bit
more complicated
and there in the experiments i used oh
adam uh which is you know uh this paper
from costas and vasilis and someone else
i'm forgetting i apologize from 2017 uh
which is talking about how to optimize
these smooth games and it works great
for us here there's been a lot of
development since i'm sure there's a lot
of opportunities to potentially improve
you know actually interesting story i
was uh 2018 we were thinking we were
doing this work we were trying to figure
out how to do it we had a lot of the
theory figured out uh not for this
inference stuff but for earlier things
but the experiments were just terrible
we couldn't optimize it right it seems
like in gans you can kind of get away
with the ascent descent
but we it was just not working for us
and i saw i was in nerfs 2018 and i saw
that costas was running the smooth game
optimization workshop
and i thought maybe i'll go learn
something and that's where i learned
about this uh i asked costas how to do
and he said oh you should use this it
was magic it just worked
and then we were able to complete this
so
that's the story for actually
implementing this actually optimizing
this thing
but let me tell you about something that
is kind of more special
or
maybe a bit
newer and beyond just smooth game
optimization which is what are the
statistical guarantees that we can give
about this approach
okay so let me start with
consistency and of course we're going to
need some regularity okay
so
we need some pretty kind of
mild regularity that's not saying too
much we're not making two sort of
complexity assumptions the only
complexity assumption we're making is
about theta
theta needs to have a finite entropy
integral this is trivial if theta is a
finite dimensional
parameter set right and this is going to
be trivial
uh otherwise we're just going to assume
that these moment functions are
equilibriuts they're bounded we're going
to assume
that our initial guess theta tilde
converges to some fixed theta tilde has
some fixed points
and in particular also the rows
evaluated theta tilde n converge to
theta tilde and both of these things
will come for free when we do k-stage
vmm but for now i'm just going to make
this as an assumption about theta tilde
n and we also need you know nice
nice second moments to the moment's
conditions
and under these assumptions and
absolutely no other assumptions we can
show consistency so let h be any smooth
universal kernel like gaussian
set
alpha to be something that's between one
and uh one over root n for later we're
going to have p equals to one half so
just anything the regularization should
be anything between 1 and 1 over root n
and then kernel v mn with this
function class is going to be consistent
that's it it's going to converge to
theta naught we didn't make any
functional assumptions about kind of
complexity in z that was actually not
important although it was important was
complexity of theta because only theta
is what we're trying to estimate
now we get this for kernel vehement
and sort of as a corollary most of the
work is about kernel vemma but we can
always play this trick
of having a
neural a set of neural nets that is you
know sufficiently big so it approximates
things sufficiently nicely
uh sort of kind of just has to
approximately several of spaces
so
by playing those tricks we can show that
the same is going to be true if you're
going to use a neural net vmm with the
fully connected neural net that has a
width and the depth that are at least
some certain amount that we're given the
paper if it's even bigger that's fine
there's no problem if it's even bigger
right the bigger the better we just have
some minimum
sizes that are necessary and then use
the kernel regularizer given by edge
it's essentially trying to mimic this
kernel vmm and therefore it inherits
this result
okay but consistency
was not what we came here for
so let's talk about asymptotic normality
so now i'm going to switch to talking
about asymptotic normality
and about efficiency i'm going to focus
on finite dimensional parameters so
theta is going to be b dimensional
in this case the covering assumption is
going to hold trivially i'm going to
need some additional assumptions i'm
going to need sort of smoothness of rho
but only second moments not like d over
2 derivatives sort of kind of thing that
says things are downscript just just
second derivatives
and i'm going to need sufficient support
so the variances are not crazy so these
functions as functions of z should be
linearly independent functions and under
these additional assumptions again no
complexity assumptions on the
conditional moment function
right the function of z
we can show that if we again
use h as some smooth universal kernel
rkhs like gaussian
and if we choose alpha to be something
between one and one over root n then the
kernel vmm is both going to be
asymptotically linear sesame particle
linear says what synthetic glue nurses
are estimate looks roughly like a sample
average of some function some unknown
function of psi this is called the
influence function plus some low order
noise so mostly it looks like a sample
average in particular
our uh estimate is going to be
asymptotically normal all right so if we
look at the scaled error theta hat n
minus and not scalar squared and that's
going to converge to normal with mean
zero and some variance you know with
some complicated expression in the paper
that also depends on the limit points
theta tilde
again
neural vmm inherits this by just playing
this trick of having really really large
neural nets that approximate everything
okay
so we got normality we almost got
inference we just have to kind of get
this v theta tilde and we're done we can
get more than that we can get
semi-parametric efficiency so in
particular we can show that
that variance from the last slide
when
theta had tilde
uh sorry theta tilde n converges to
theta naught right so the asymptotic
covariance of emm when we our initial
guess converges eventually to theta
naught as it will if we do two-stage vmm
that is actually the semi-parametric
efficiency bound for estimating theta
naught in the model consisting of all
distributions satisfying the conditional
moments okay so it's kind of like what
hansen got for the marginal moment model
but now we're looking at the model
specified by the conditional moment
problem right so this is in fact the
semi-parametric efficiency bound and
therefore these uh k-stage
kernel or neural vmms are going to be
semi-parameter completely efficient in
the conditional model
so just a quick
recap what are we talking about what is
the semi-parametrically efficient
essentially what we're saying is that if
you look for any beta
at the
asymptotic mean squared error of
estimating beta transpose theta naught
right so some aspect of theta naught
some contrast
some univariate
aspect of data not that you care about
right we're going to achieve the minimum
possible asymptotic mean square there
right so minimum possible either
literally minimum possible among all
regular estimators in this model
or we can also think about it as among
all estimators in some locally meaning
max sets okay so this is sort of classic
semi-parametric efficiency theory
so we checked all the boxes we got
everything we want except inference
so what does influence mean here
inference means estimate that right
estimate this covariance once you
estimate that covariance
then we know how to construct confidence
intervals assessment particle normal
with this covariance you just do plus
minus two standard errors or any sort of
test like that
okay so how do we estimate that
so we could literally estimate it by
again going back to nui and kind of
doing non-parametric regressions and
figuring it out that would be some
consistent way and really only
consistency for the covariance in order
to get valid confidence intervals
but there's actually a nice way to layer
vmm on top of this
to estimate this so we can show that if
v theta knot is this efficiency bound
and you care about some aspect of it
right so some quadratic form in it
right why do we care about this thing
because this is going to be the
asymptotic variance of beta transpose
theta hat now
that is going to be given by its own
smooth game right again we're going to
look at
a game between
this b dimensional gamma and f but now
it's soup instead of in soup
so all we're going to do is we're going
to take this characterization of the
efficiency bound and we're going to
replace expectations with empirical
expectations
and add a regularizer because we
okay and then that's going to be our vmm
style estimate of this variance
and we can show
that under these sort of same conditions
that we have before kernel vmm's
standard error estimates is going to be
consistent right this way of estimating
the standard error is really going to
converge to the true
uh standard error
that we care about so in particular if
we have some aspect psi of theta naught
that we care about we can construct a
confidence interval just by taking psi
of the vm investment plus minus
two of these guys when we plug in the
gradient of psi for beta right that is
going to be exact 95 coverage
and we have a way of optimizing i guess
again using kernel gram matrices for the
kernel case so all good
so now
in the time that's left
i'm gonna try and walk through some of
the experiments of actually trying to
apply this in practice
and seeing what are the benefits
of of using this what are the benefits
in terms of meets cordera we said you
know i said that we should get minimum
sport error well asymptotically how does
that bear out in practice and you know
how does the inference work
this is sort of the first inference
method for these minimax methods does it
does it give us what we want
so first you know rather than tell you
about the setup of the experiment
there's no point to it kind of i'll tell
you you know we look at first the simple
setting and then a more complicated
setting
and
at a high level the story is just
following if you're interested in kind
of the specifics of the setup of the
experiment you look in the paper but
here i'm just looking at different
estimators the vmm estimator these sieve
estimators various sieve estimators as
recommended in the iron chen paper with
different like versions of that
these sort of maximum mean restriction
methods and a naive method that's just
doing plane regression no control for
the
iv
and in this sort of simple setting kind
of everything works everything is
getting reasonable msc
and it's essentially just showing
everything works as it should and for
example vmm is not exploded
when you go to a slightly more complex
scenario that's where we see
things
play out these sieve methods are just
they're just insane right the permit
polynomials it's actually here we use
the b splines this is completely
unwieldy in practice
and the msc is just not even i can't
even write it down in this table without
fitting in a slide
uh the vmm methods seem to perform
reasonably well uh you know better than
uh just using this maximum moment things
okay so maybe we can attribute that to
efficiency right that we're actually
getting the best possible asymptotic msc
right so cool failure embassy should be
smaller and it seems to bear on practice
here we can also talk about not just the
msc of the thetas but what is the l2
error of predicting right predict uh the
actual incident level average over you
know average of scared errors over the
insulin levels
and we see you know much better
performance as n grows
then especially the sieve method but
also the maximum method
so
for inference you know inference is hard
we get about the right kind of coverage
definitely for small n we're
undercovering a lot for a slightly
bigger n we're getting uh more nominal
coverage close to this 95
percent coverage but it's definitely if
you also look at how well we're
estimating is an error we're getting it
about right okay so that's
uh even when we use sort of these very
complex function classes
now
here i was focusing a lot about uh
finite dimensional theta right so we
actually proved consistency for general
theta non-parametric theta we just
needed the theta class to be donskar
but efficiency and inference
only makes sense
if we have a finite dimensional theta
right because we're talking about
efficiency bound we need some finite
dimensional parameter to talk about
we're talking about asymptotic normality
we need to talk about some finite
dimensional theta so what about general
nonparametric theorem right so this
this recent paper by d collidon
bastille system is going to tell us
about later this week provided some
really nice non-parametric finite sample
guarantees right so they take this
unweighted mini-max method
and they show that under
in terms of kind of the non-parametric
complexity
of big theta and of script f they
provide the finite sample guarantees
but we know
that these plain minimax methods are not
efficient okay so we get the right rates
maybe but
we need maybe waiting to get efficiency
but efficiency is not a story about
rates it's a story about the leading
constant on first order terms
it's hard to
explain
kind of what's the effect of optimal
weighting in terms of finite sample
guarantees um because it would
essentially be the the leading constants
but it's actually hard to characterize
in this case
uh when we're talking about these
non-parametric cases
maybe you know i'm thinking about this i
haven't had uh i haven't been able to
figure this out but it does seem that in
practice even though we're not talking
about finite dimensional theta adding
this regularization
does help us when even we're doing
non-parametric estimation
so just to give you a sense of this here
i'm looking at trying to estimate
different functions so either a sine a
step function or absolute function or
linear function but the noise is going
to be confounded with the x
right so even though i should be fitting
a step function here if i look at the
data it just looks like a line going up
right and if i actually estimate this
with
normal light regression that's what i
see
but really i should be using the
instrument which is not shown on the
slide but i'm also giving some
instrument that is able to tease out
what is the structural causal generative
model here
and here i'm looking at a variety of
methods that are trying to now learn
this iv regression in a non-parametric
way they're not just trying to find
these finding dimensional theta
actually trying to fit some deep neural
net some rich uh
iv regression
right so
in these different settings we can look
at what happens when we just try to
regress directly but what happens when
we try to do things based on sort of
linear
uh
linear iv with some sort of
basis expansion and that works when the
basic expansion is right right either
it's linear when it's like
quadratic-like it seems to work okay
but you know it doesn't work for step
and here are different approaches that
you could apply you could either
literally do gmm on the neural nets or
you could do this sort of mini max
methods
or you could do sort of two-stage
methods
and they seem to improve
but they also have some failing points
and it seems that adding this
regularization
and trying to control
which moments you're optimizing and
which moments you're spending expressive
energy on can really help you in
practice right but this is outside the
scope of the semi-parametric efficiency
results this is just something i've
observed
empirically
i think i'm out of time so rather than
talking about these applications right
so here i have some more results these
are actually
other papers uh this
paper
uh is from nurse this is another recent
paper where we look at how to use this
for uh confounded peas
so rather than telling you about this
i'll just recap here
and tell you the punch line
here okay we do better of course that's
what the experiments are going to show
okay so
i'll go to the conclusion
so we started these conditional moments
models are extremely useful for a lot of
problems it's a workhorse of
economics right all these iv or
industrial organization
have some sort of conditional moment
problem underlying them
but it's not just in economics it's also
really important offline around i mean
jason showed us that all those primal
dual mini max
estimators for q functions for density
ratios they're coming from conditional
moment models
and it's also especially important when
you're looking at confounded settings
where we actually can only use
conditional moment problem models you
can't use sort of repeated regression
sort of dp like fqi is essentially a dp
method dynamic programming with a
regression so in these condolence
settings you really can't do regression
you really have to think about this as a
conditional moment model it's more like
the iv version of offline rl
and you know i didn't get to talk about
this but you can actually also do this
for cost sensitive classification i'll
just mention it in quick insight from
that setting which is
if you're looking at cost sensitive
logistic regression
logistic regression is actually
not optimal then even though emily up
says that you know if you're actually
fitting something in
the case where
something is really a logistic response
it's optimal it's not optimal in the
cost sensitive setting and you really
have to do something more clever to get
efficiency
right so sieves is sort of the classic
approach to this
uh you know it's been developed in the
in the past
millennium
and it was shown to have nice properties
but it doesn't work in practice it's
just completely unwieldy so that's
recently led people to look at these
more mls minimax approaches but they
lose the noble winning efficiency and
inference of these classic methods so
what i try to do is try to go back to
optimally weighted gmm
and try to directly translate that to
this minimax setting with general
function
classes
more directly in order to keep that
optimal weighting and we showed that
that gave us some documentary
semiconductor efficiency and a way to
estimate standard errors and it seems to
work well in practice even beyond
finding dimensional theta but i can't
say anything about that theoretically i
would love to hear if you guys have
thoughts about what to do there
thanks
thank you nathan
um
are there any questions for nathan uh
also nathan if you can see your chat uh
over there in case there are uh
questions from the online participant
please monitor that otherwise i'll
monitor the questions in the room
okay yeah
hi nathan so i was wondering if there is
any trade-off between the statistical
efficiency versus the computational
efficiency because you mentioned you can
use this fully connected neural networks
but the resulting mi max problem is
going to be non-convex
right non-concave then it is very hard
to solve it
i haven't thought about this a lot
honestly i was more so concerned with
the
statistical properties and i hoped that
you know smarter people like costas
figured out how to do the optimization
um
so i don't i don't know anything
theoretically about this right what i do
know is for the
kernel version
right even for the kernel version the
inner premium is closed form
but it's still some crazy optimization
problem for example if you're optimizing
for neural networks data like you're
doing neural net regression
um
so i think that's a good question i
don't know how to study the
computational complexity because it's
just always going to be some weirdo
thing it's never going to be convex
holy time solvable uh at least not it's
not so clear to me
do you have some thoughts on this
i think most of us here are still trying
to figure it out right
[Music]
oh yeah thank you
thank you
thanks for the talk
one question is like one way to maybe
equalize the variance of the moment
would be to just standardize the moments
divide by the variance
and optimize
that objective like a minimax objective
where every moment is divided by its
variance
do you know how that would
compare so you're saying
instead of doing minus one quarter
put a
do this yes standardize the standardize
the every moment by dividing weights
would it be what you're saying
yeah purple divided by orange yeah
something like that yeah okay so arg
means soup purple divided by orange
yes i think on the right way that should
be equivalent
i think
um
that's a good question sorry i don't
have a but then i'll think about it
that's a really really great question
so i have a question maybe related to
this i mean a little bit confused so if
this theta and tilde is a bad uh
initialized domain
what is gonna break like your confidence
intervals are too big so what what is uh
what will break is the following
so imagine
first that it's so bad
right that maybe maybe let's say row of
say of when theta is equal to zero rows
your row of it is zero right so if we
start at zero this will be completely
eliminated
right so we'll only have this mini max
thing uh that we had before
so
what this tells you is
how should you weight the different
moments so that came directly from
optimally weighted gmm
where
gamma
hat here
it should have been what you really
wanted was you wanted the covariance of
these moment conditions
but you didn't know at theta not but you
didn't know state or not so you did a
theta tilde right so you could look at
putting an identity matrix here and
saying you know let's just look at the
two norm
once you've done that you've got an
initial guess for theta and then you can
try and guess get a better guess for
gamma hats so what happens if you
imagine like look what happens with with
this if i
put the identity here right so i don't
weight things correctly
and i have
duplicates of the moments so maybe they
have
f1 and f2 or equal to one another and
then there's f3 which is another one i
really should somehow equally wait f1
and f3 and forget about f2 but i'm
doubling up on f1 f2 by saying i care
about twice
the squared moment for f1 and once the
squared moment for f3
really because those f1 and f2 are
perfectly correlated because they're the
same function they're the same f i
should discount that that's exactly what
this gamma inverse does
right so that's what it does in
optimally weighted gm it makes sure that
i'm eliminating sort of these uh
duplicates duplicate moments and it's
exactly what it's doing here because
the the way that this plays out
in order to show this thing for kernel
bmm
is doing a sort of
argument like this where everything is
now like
these
operators on rkhs's rather than matrices
uh and you need a lot of regularity and
you need to do regularization because
these are universal et cetera
but if you get a wrong theta tilde it
means you don't know how to correctly
rewrite things
now you might think why don't i just
stick theta itself here
i don't know
for why that's bad i think
you know it's kind of related to
maybe i hope this is yeah kind of like
this double sampling in offline rl
um
yeah sorry did that answer your question
because this so you care about yeah yes
i was also asking more uh what like
wherein your theorem is reflected that
uh
you know if theta and tilde is you know
a bad choice something will break
yeah like uh in this convert there was
some uh
yeah okay so it will affect your
variance that's that i guess that was
depend on the on the on the p limit of
theta tilde n which is assumed to be
existing to be equal to the
two theta tilde so there's some thing
like this and
the psd
smallest
value that this matrix can take is that
theta naught
that is going to be psd preceding v v
theta tilde for any theta tilde v theta
naught is going to be p is the smallest
respected like the psd column ordering
okay yeah so i guess that was my
question yeah and then um okay
so in practice you hope that you are i
mean if you do two-step of your vmm
framework you hope that you'll get some
reasonable theta tilde there is that the
whole you don't just have to hope i mean
that was the consistency right so
consistency told me
that kernel v m with any theta tilde
just like whatever it doesn't matter
just put zeros in there will be
consistent
therefore i can plug this theorem
into
this theorem to say that if my theta
tilde n
is doing kernel vmm first with some bad
theta tilde n
then i'm golden then it's fine that's
right and that's what i try to summarize
here that k stage vmm with at least two
stages
uh will be semi-parametrically efficient
yeah okay that makes sense thank you
yeah
thanks for the question
uh sir arthur
ah nissan thanks for the talk um i just
have a question about this uh kernel
regularized fully connected neural nets
versus just uh kernel methods
so uh i'm just wondering like given
i'm not
sure i understood completely but it
seems that your colonel regularizer of
your neuron that's a sort of to make it
behave more like a kernel method in your
analysis
if i read your table right it seemed
that it was doing a little bit worse is
that correct in the more complicated
models
it's
a bit of a watch it's hard to say i
think i think like so in the simple
setting it seemed to do better the more
complex thing you're right it seemed to
do a little worse
i'm not sure what to eat of it i mean i
think
here my regularization is actually not
the kernel regularization it's this uh
frobenius regularization this cheat
regularization that i didn't actually
theoretically characterize
um and i would hope
that
the neural nets would also have some
inductive bias that should help
but um
yeah it doesn't bear in the theory in
the theory it's just
the neural vmm only works because it's
mimicking the kernel vienna
uh but your point is like maybe maybe
it's actually worse because it's only
mimicking it
maybe
i'm not sure right yeah no i i mean i'm
just curious so
uh whether in practice there was a
difference in the performance for
different settings uh of the neural
versus the
kernel method
um
scenario for
for for the policy learning where the
neural thing did better
okay thanks
and at least asymptotically they should
all behave the same
right so if there are no more questions
let's uh thank nathan again
thank you nathan
okay
so i'm wondering can you just see my
slides and hear an ominous voice in the
room where you also see me waving at you
guys i can see you yeah
okay
[Music]
bye-bye thanks thank you
and
yeah for those of you who are physically
here there's a reception outside